it's too soon to fully understand what a
u.s withdrawal from afghanistan will
mean for the region the ramifications
will play out over years possibly
decades
one thing security experts say to expect
will be a u.s refocus to the
indo-pacific and that is welcomed by
countries from japan to the philippines
and america is not alone on this the
european union is developing a new
strategy for the region right now france
is the only european country with
significant naval forces in asia but
things are starting to change germany is
sending its first warship over in almost
20 years one of the main reasons has to
do with trade about 40 percent of global
trade goes through the straits of
malacca and about a fifth to a third of
trade travels through the south china
sea
we have guerns fistic of the german
institute for international and security
affairs and he is an active duty officer
in the german armed forces thank you so
much for joining us
it's my pleasure
so i want to start
tell us what can one frigate in the
indo-pacific do
from an operational perspective not much
but it's clearly a political sign a
political sign from the german
government
to the region in the pacific region
and china has not reacted well to this
and has criticized germany for sending
quote uh confusing signals and germany
has asked for a port call in shanghai
which beijing has yet to grant so what
is germany's message here
so in accordance with the
guidelines for the indian pacific issued
by the german government last year
one part of the operation of the route
for the german frigate is also to
show
our understanding of the international
law and the freedom of navigation china
has a quite different understanding of
this
interpretation of the international
rules and
the freedom of navigation
especially in the south china sea so
there is the friction between germany
and china
now i think for a lot of people asia is
literally half a world away for the
european union i want to ask about the
interest here in a new eu strategy for
the indo-pacific
the
asia region or indo-pacific region as it
is also called
is
one of the biggest
trading partners for europe not just for
germany but also for europe china but
also under other countries australia
indonesia japan
so especially the maritime
domain in this region is the highway
transport way of goods resources
coming to europe or going in the other
direction
having been produced in europe then back
to asian countries
i think some people must wonder how much
of this is happening because of u.s
pressure on the eu due to the rocky
bilateral relations we're seeing between
the u.s and china and how much does it
actually have to do with european
interests what do you say to people who
are wondering that
i would say um
for many experts or pundits
it has been clear since a few years that
there is a growing
risk in the
asia-pacific region in the indo-pacific
region
we do have this rivalry between the us
and china but also the west i would say
about norms and how we
apply international regulations how we
conduct trade
etc
but also in europe it has become clear
in recent years more clearer not just to
pundits and experts but also to the
[Music]
broader public to
politicians in the parliament what kind
of risk we do have in the in the pacific
region that was one of the main points
why the german government has published
last year the guidelines for the
indo-pacific region
garen fistic thank you so much for
joining us
you